another day of heavy rain
flash flooding and rising river levels
have inundated homes and properties with
emergency service teams called in to
rescue animals trapped in flood waters
obviously we've got gonna get him out
now so it's happened
it's happened overnight and um yeah
gotta get him out
thousands of people in greater sydney
have been ordered to evacuate their
homes
suburbs are underwater and some
communities are expected to be isolated
for days the storm cell delivered heavy
rain with some parts of sydney copping
more than australia's annual average
rainfall in three days
so we're really asking communities today
to uh to bear with us keep working with
us
it has been a difficult four days
there's nowhere there's no gilding that
lilly we're not quite through it yet a
natural disaster has also been declared
in the state of new south wales
the intense weather system is forecast
to ease in sydney but authorities say
the flood danger is still high
this event is far from over
please don't be complacent wherever you
are please be careful when you're
driving on our roads obviously there is
still substantial risk for flash
flooding across our state this stricken
cargo vessel carrying hundreds of tonnes
of fuel off the coast of sydney has been
forced to anchor after a rescue attempt
failed
rescue crews will try again when the
weather improves
this storm is expected to continue until
friday and is now tracking north along
australia's east coast even the state of
queensland is bracing for unseasonal
downfalls
sarah clark al jazeera brisbane
australia